okay mission technology I need to
distinguish between a couple of
different ideas within motion okay
because right away particularly if you
have never done physics right you'll get
very very confused if you don't know
exactly what we're talking about when we
say you know this is equal to something
or this quantity is changing its go away
okay so the first idea is that I want to
contrast our distance and displacement
now if you're a person if you're not
physics minded and these things might
sound might be synonymous to you okay
they're like how far something lose and
true enough that's the basic idea
beneath it okay but the idea about
distance is how far have you traveled
okay not far you travel
okay for instance I'm walking back and
forth in front of this whiteboard right
so I don't know what is it like it's
three two and a half meters from here to
there okay so as I walk back and forth
okay
I've moved of your turnout meters and
now who's five and now we're seven and a
half okay so that's a travel question
okay but displacement is quite different
displacement thinks about where do you
start and how far are you from that
starting point okay how far are you from
your origin if you like okay so now that
I'm back where I started from where I
was talking about right my displacement
is zero that sort of makes sense okay my
distance is B another know whenever four
to ten meters okay so that's how far
I've actually gone but in terms of
displacement I'm where I began okay so
my displacement would be zero now along
with that the these two ideas also go
with a rate of change that has exactly
the same difference okay
and when you've sort of heard us talking
about this and alluded to it before in
terms of rates of change you would say
how far have you traveled distance how's
that changed you recall that speed speed
is distance over time okay now when we
think about displacement which isn't
about how where you are relative to
where you begin okay we give it a
different name we call it velocity okay
so velocity is not distance over time it
is displacement over time
okay now along with this let me get
another come up let me try to introduce
to sir mom some weird words for you may
be that again the fizzy espalier this
makes sense and these two distance and
speed okay we call them um scalar
numbers what that means is it just
represents the quantity or our magnitude
or size and because it's a size much
like length length is a scalar number
the smallest it could be is zero okay it
can be zero or it can be positive in
terms of distance travel you can't
travel negative meters right cuz it's
like well how far am I gone I started at
zero and then it just started to go up
from there right so therefore scalar
numbers they're the smallest thing can
be is zero okay but they're usually
positive now velocity and displacement
on the other hand okay they are not
scalar numbers we call them vectors okay
that's a really really fancy
intimidating word you might have heard
them in connection to matrices it's a
whole versity university topic and it's
very very confusing but all it means is
there's not just the quantity or a sighs
there's a quantity and there's a
direction okay so this is quantity this
is quantity plus direction okay so for
that reason of a vector can be negative
okay or a displacement could be negative
okay for instance if if we said okay the
middle of the whiteboard that I'm
standing on okay I'm gonna call that my
orange and that's my starting point and
over this way I'm gonna call that
positive because I'm thinking about a
direction as well as where I've gone
again that means negative okay so if
this is the origin and I'm standing over
here now both my displacement oh my
falsely velocity what
negative okay does that make sense
because I'm to the well from my
perspective but to the left okay now
when I come back okay I come back to the
origin so my displacement was zero what
happened to my velocity well it was
negative and then it was positive and
they exactly cancel themselves out okay
and that's why my total displacement is
zero because the velocity sort of
illuminate each other if you like so the
key to get here is that this can go
negative when we're talking about
velocity you can say minus five meters
per second okay
whereas if I said speed that would be
meaningless okay we just want what's
that what's the quantity what's the size
now